[Music]
when you think of dominant regions and
esports there are a few that instantly
come to mind korea denmark china all of
these nations dominated an esport at one
point or another some of them still do
but while some of the wealthiest nations
in the world jockeyed for power another
country was hard at work trying to grow
the golden age of cs was every single
day of the week you'd go to a land cafe
to play with your friends brazilian fps
players took matters into their own
hands and with almost no money or
support created one of the most
passionate communities and some of the
greatest players the world has ever seen
leaving coldzera in a one-on-four
there's the first
looking for a second he connects it oh
and he gets a third as well surely he's
not gonna pull this one up oh caldera
the man the myth the beast
every single time still winnable falling
needs the ace clutch clutches
oh come on falling yeah the blood's
flowing now
oh
he gets it
he's just hiding he's just waiting with
two seconds left he's gonna be standing
up getting the head shot at one and that
might have been absolutely perfect taco
getting the quad kill and saving the
round brilliant play
the rise of brazil is one of the most
incredible stories in esports and
despite some ups and downs they're not
done yet
[Music]
hey folks before we get into this video
i just want to make sure you're all sub
to the channel and if you haven't done
it already then please hit the sub
button and turn on notifications really
does help all right so i'm gonna guess
that when you think about brazil
competitive gaming might not be the
first thing that comes to mind you
probably think about the beaches the
favelas and soccer but over the last two
decades brazil has become one of esports
biggest powerhouse regions especially
when it comes to first person shooters
at this point esports are ingrained in
brazil's dna and now another one on one
has referred to the post plan there it
is
[Applause]
taking the map and the series europe's
gone led out forward brazilian teams
have won world championships in cs go
and rainbow six siege man they've gone
deep at international tournaments and
plenty of other games too so how did a
country where access to internet and
home computers is rare become one of the
most feared and respected esports
nations in the world
well as it turns out it's thanks to just
a few people but let's start at the
beginning brazil's competitive history
began in the early 2000s in internet
cafes every home
neighborhood as like sao paulo it's a
gigantic city right 30 million people
every block had a land center and it was
always packed and you'd have to wait in
line for
bc to open up and everyone wanted to
play because their friends were playing
cs 1.6 and dota were both available but
cs was a lot more popular as more and
more people got into it a few players
began to really stand out from the pack
and one of those players was gabriel
fallen toledo fallen wasn't just
brazil's best he was literally the
future of the country's esports scene he
used to play conor counter-strike 1.6
and four years ago the scene was pretty
dead he thought like oh what am i
supposed to do to keep like kind of
things going here in brazil so he would
like give classes for people to get
better at the game they would pay for
had this class and with this money he
started building like tournaments fallen
and his compatriots took the world by
storm by 2006 they were representing
brazil in international tournaments for
both 1.6 and source over the next few
years fallen became the face of
brazilian cs but amidst all of fallen's
dominance the brazilian scene hit a bit
of a roadblock see nobody was really
playing cs go when it came out the rest
of the world had moved on to this new
game and brazil was running out of
international tournaments to compete in
for the old ones fallen wanted to give
back the scene that gave him so much so
he teamed up with gaulis to try to
revive brazilian fps esports as a
professional player as someone who was
actually trying to leave from the game
there wasn't many treatments to play in
brazil on cs 1.6
and cs go so at that time specifically
we had some very cool projects going on
in brazil
some of phil gallis was actually
participating at the time you guys know
gaudius by now of his recent strengths
and at the time he had a very cool
project bringing some cool games some
cool different titles and doing a lot of
cool competitions with big prize monies
fallen and gallus started running
tournaments to make sure brazil's most
talented players could continue to make
a living it was quite fun to have this
challenge i've been playing more than
one game at the same time and in brazil
when i joined up with fur the twins
lucas and hannie
we in fnx we did a super good job we i
think we won six of seven crossfire
tournaments in a row all the cs 1.6
tournaments at the time you see this
wasn't just a way for fallen to compete
in more tournaments and travel the world
himself it was a way to keep the love
for fps games alive in brazil as a whole
without fallen in gallus's efforts
brazilian esports might have died right
there and then
but instead when cs go finally blew up
in brazil they were ready to join the
fight first still above on the connector
and they're both gonna walk through
first should peek out at any moment
doesn't matter zqk and steel get it it's
over just like that cloud9 get
obliterated
against the brazilians kaboom i don't
think anyone saw that coming and cloud9
looks stunned they look speechless
fallen and his countrymen burst onto the
international cs go scene in 2015 and
quickly became a lineup no one could
ignore they jumped from roster to roster
top aiding two back-to-back majors and
cementing their status as a team you had
to respect but fallen wasn't just
putting all his focus into being the
best cs player he could be he was
simultaneously helping raise up young
brazilian talent he founded games
academy to develop brazilian players the
same way that countries with deep talent
pools like denmark and sweden did he was
creating the next generation of
brazilian cs superstars we have a
functioning ecosystem now they have we
have tournaments that run you have
spotlight previews for the tournament
for the players to actually be
participating in every week where they
can show off themselves show off their
game and the organizations are learning
a little bit more about the player value
as well prices are inflated
so
every team learned that
i'm not going to be a buyer forever i
need to start up start producing my own
talent fallen called taco fnx and coach
zeus up from games academy on top of
recruiting a young coldzera and when
they all finally came together the team
popped off everything riding on taco
here they almost lined up he gets the
one spray in turns around for it second
kill and there it is the grenade has
gone and luminosity are in the semis off
a major tournament adrenaline is a one
versus four retake with an
awp and there it is cold he's going to
take his head off and luminosity will
find themselves in the grand finals
against na'vi
and now it is a one-on-two taco looking
to see if he could close it out here and
win it for the brazilians it's gonna be
a big turn around there hits the head
shot on susan now it's a one-on-one
guardian versus taco it may just be
destined to be and it's through venocity
winning their first major championship
even after the roster jumped from
luminosity to sk gaming they kept
dominating and now it's just all in the
details easy for sk to pick it up here
trying to walk through the smoke but
it's just not gonna happen sk gaming
second major championship in a row they
are your winners
the brazilian titans conquered the world
winning two back-to-back majors and
making history as the first ever
non-european team to win a major and on
top of that they were winning everything
else too with a legion of passionate
brazilian fans cheering them on they
proved that brazil could develop
unbelievable talent and create a fan
base like no other that era was brazil's
international coming out party we've
only been talking about one team but
brazil was dominating everywhere
immortals came in a close second of the
2017 krakow major in 2018 black dragons
won the crossfire world championship and
team liquid won the rainbow six pro
league season seven finals but that
untouchable era of dominance was about
to come to an end
[Music]
taco can't do anything the pandemonium
is 16 rounds and cloud9 are in the grand
finals of a major tournament
no one's seen twist yet gonna get the
one kill jumping down picking up a
second a big double for twist and that
leaves fallen alone he's gonna go down
and liquid do it knocking out sk gaming
off the tournament and moving right into
the semi-finals it's a crossfire set
stewie's just getting into position now
and he'll spot him crossing over cloud9
moves on and sk go home over the next
couple of years the so-called sk core
started to fall apart players were
leaving results were getting worse and
brazilian dominance generally faded at
least in cs
any minute now there's oscar with a kill
on bolts and fur is going to go down
that 16-6 that's mousesport not sk out
of the tournament he might be able to do
it he's done it greyhound it's going to
be 16-11 they've done the impossible tim
sk gaming will be knocked out of iem
sydney
on day one despite all the losses though
brazilian fans never stopped loving
their teams brazil's fan base is a
constant through line in the history of
its competitive gaming scene hell it's a
constant in the history of brazil period
brazilian fandom isn't just for football
football is like the peak for what we're
known for if you have a president
competing the brazilian crowd is there
we love to be patriotic right everyone
can
we can talk [ __ ] on brazil no one else
can talk [ __ ] on brazil where does it
like we hype it up and that's kind of
how it goes brazilian fans are known for
just how hype they can get and most cs
players say that brazil is their
favorite place to play because of that
but the passion that makes the fanbase
so special and exciting can also make it
toxic for example during a match between
mibr and chaos esports club chaos's leaf
made a few plays that mibr's players
found suspicious at the end of the game
they called him up for cheating and
fallen broadcasted the accusations to
his entire twitter audience over the
next 24 hours leaf received an endless
barrage of online abuse and death
threats from brazilian fans i was more
surprised
to see the reaction of the community
being so hostile um
and maybe i shouldn't be um the problem
being is that we had players in this
case that have
said not to call people up before
because it does this doing the exact
same thing obviously in the case of
fallen that that's that's pretty true
and i think that a little bit ignorant
of what they're following is capable of
what what implications that has
obviously sending death threats is
unacceptable but it's not a problem
unique to brazilian fans online hate is
unfortunately a universal language the
problem was that brazilian fans were
developing a bit of a toxic reputation
in 2020. back during a game between mibr
and another brazilian squad furia
twitter drama between the two teams
erupted when fur called furio players
out for some truly petty [ __ ] fallen and
his team helped create the avenue for
teams like fyria to prosper and now it
seemed like the veterans were trying to
turn the community against the young
up-and-comers they turn on them in
obviously a game that is very very
important and they put them on blast on
social media in front of hundreds of
thousands of people who we know are
they're a very passionate fan base right
we know that they're a very passionate
fan base fallen ended up apologizing for
his role in both situations mibr's
reputation took a hit along with their
results by the end of the year the
unbroken legacy of the team that took
brazilian esports to the top of the
world was tarnished two kills and now
the 1v1 could you imagine a better
moment up against fallen
the man who brought him to the stage now
might keep him from it the time the bomb
goes in fallen's there just to the right
he misses oh sarah breaking brazilian
hearts
despite all the drama though fallen was
still the godfather of brazilian esports
and his efforts over the years meant
that the scene didn't just up and vanish
when he fell from grace all that work
that fallen zeus and gallus put into
their scene it wasn't for nothing they
planted the seed in their communities
and it was growing the whole time furia
rose up as one of the most exciting
teams in cs he's in library right now
and there's two players they're
completely unaware say hello to our
little friend que serato brazil
absolutely dominated siege in 2021
by people
that is the round in 2020 brazilian
hearts were broken but like a phoenix
nip rise from the ashes to claim the
hammer at the six invitational 2021.
as empire need to get that diffuser down
five seconds left but it's been
surrendered and dale believe in magic
michael because i do and team one does
as they win the mexico major faze have
everything in their power and that's the
diffuser years and years of hard work
pay off for the brazilian squad and five
gentlemen earn their first major here in
sweden faze clan are your champions we
saw a record-breaking representation
from brazil at the stockholm major the
first cs go major in two years did he
actually do this there's one knife out
oh
save
taking down lucky what a godlike play by
october 2021 gallus became the most
watched streamer in the world and fallen
the man who started it all found a new
home on team liquid sure they didn't
always pop off during his time there but
he was playing some of the best cs he
had in years and looked like he was
having more fun than he had in a long
time that was it guys we got our list
and i'd like to take this time to
apologize to absolutely nobody not of
the chains if you guys
for me our fuel go [ __ ] out of the
measure we're gonna win it out
but why does this all matter why do we
care so much about what people like
fallen did for brazil why do we care
about one country's success at video
games at all because brazil is a shining
example of why esports matter to so many
people when we went to blast sao paulo
ricardo our manager at the time told us
the most
eye-opening experience i've ever seen
one of which is
he just pointed to the arena where we're
having a really bad event and he's told
us guys i know you're not happy with
what you're putting out here in terms of
gameplay but be proud don't be sad
because everyone in this arena here is
for you so there was like 10 000 people
in the arena for us but he wasn't
talking about them he pointed at the
security guard that was doing escorts he
pointed at the people that were cleaning
that people that were selling everything
like you're indirectly
making so many jobs available brazil is
not one of the wealthiest countries in
the world like most other regions that
dominate esports it's a place where
people can use esports as a temporary
escape from their circumstances as a way
out of a bad situation for the most
talented fallen did what he did to
create a new path for himself and other
brazilians one that was about grinding
out a game he loved and making sure
others could do the same there are
people all over the world who want that
but in brazil
it's real
i hear pigeons outside my window
which is weird you'd think that the
pigeons would leave because it's cold
and yet here we are i can just hear them
cooing i don't think it's going to be on
the mic but i'm going to hear it
[Music]